hey leute was geht ab und es willkommen
bei einem neuen video immer wieder auf
einem kanal und so ich würde mal sagen
ganz passend zur wm 2014 haben ich und
mein kumpel uns heute mal ganz was
besonderes für euch einfallen lassen und
zwar geht es heute um fünf arten von
fans ich würde sagen ich will angela
band viel spaß mit dem video namens
bitte ein ganz bisschen gelassen falls
euer name fällt oder so und wenn ihr
teil 2 sehen wollt dann sage ich jetzt
schon mal gebt einfach mal daumen nach
oben dann weiß ich bescheid und jetzt
ganz viel spaß mit dem video wurde war
wird in deutschland gewinnt heute 20
alter ich wette 20 ich habe bei tipico
szene gesetzt junge lover nicht vor
locker 4 0 4 0 3 nicht so gut vier
millionen spiel kommen keine weitere
unsere frauen aber wenn ich gewinne ich
deine diesmal wirklich mal scheiße 1 0
für spanien
ach ich hab mein spanien kann ich das
mal
hubertus ja weißt du was ein sieg von
unseren deutschen nationalmannschaft
heute über frankreich für unser land für
deutschland bedeuten könnte ja durchaus
es könnte wirtschaft hinein wir würden
ein ganz anderes licht auf die
französische revolution
diesen weg will
beim letzten aufeinandertreffen dieser
beiden mannschaften sich mit der hilde
gehalt im stadion
damals ging auch die hosen bis knapp
unter die hüfte circa hier
da war nix mit dich stieg beinschoner
etc
auf dem bolzplatz gegangen viele rollen
lassen nicht nix hier harakiri hacke
spitze eins zwei drei mal zu sie habe
ihm von meinem dieser noch fünf große
cloud wurde ihm vom studio durchziehen
rasmus winzer drei tagen klimas willst
du ganz getan was machst du für sachen
drei tage wenn du musst deine mutter
nicht erzählen dass es doch wieder der
ausschlag geben dafür ein gramm
so leute das war sind so leider schon
wieder mit diesem video falls es euch
gefallen hat oder falls ihr es wirklich
davon überzeugt seid teil 2 sehen zu
wollen ergibt auf jeden fall mal daumen
nach oben oder schreibt sie in die
kommentare irgendwie sowas halt und
japan ihr nicht vergessen wenn ihr
nichts mehr verpassen weil ich ja bei
5000 abonnenten oder so ansonsten
instagram facebook und co alles um in
der video beschreibung und hinten links
geht es weiter mit meinem letzten video
das war so ein get ready with me haare
hoch sein scheiß und so und hier unten
rechts zur schule heute und schule
früher auf jeden fall auch ganz cool
geboren ist um ihn ist heftig bei euch
angekommen und ja schöne pfingstwetter
und wir sehen uns nächstes wochenende
wieder haut rein